[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
22 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Very, very excited about
our interviews with an S.
MARK MANDEL: Interviews
with an S, very sneaky.
We're sneaking in
an extra interview.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Extra interview today.
So we're going to have for
our cool thing of the week--
it's going to be an
interview, and then
our main content is
going to be an interview,
and then for the
question of the week
it will not be an interview.
MARK MANDEL: No, it will
not be an interview.
No, no, no.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so we're going
to have for our main
content of the week
we're going to be
talking with Rae Wang.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
We're going to talk
to her about IAM.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
And then at the end,
we're going to be talking
about something quite cool,
which is about-- how do you
pronounce it?
Caching?
Cay-shing?
MARK MANDEL: Cay-shing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's wrong.
Caching.
So yeah, we're going to
be talking about caching
and what you can do.
There's some cool
stuff coming on.
But before that, we have
our cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're going to be
talking to Brendan Burns, lead
engineer on the Kubernetes
project.
We met up with him at GCP
NEXT, and had a really great
conversation with him.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, he gave
a-- I think he gave a talk.
No, he did not give a
talk, but he was around
and we decided to interview him.
And we have it.
It's a pretty short
interview, so we
decided that it could be a
very cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Let's get to it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, hi,
Brendan, Brendan Burns.
How are you doing?
BRENDAN BURNS: Hi.
Doing great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, for those that
don't know who Brendan Burns
is, he's a famous person that
made a video about what is
faster-- to start a GKE cluster
or to make a latte.
BRENDAN BURNS: That's
true, actually.
And it's gotten
faster, so I'm going
to have to up my
latte-making game, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that is pretty awesome.
So, tell us a little
bit about yourself.
Who are you?
What do you do at Google?
BRENDAN BURNS: Sure.
So, I've done a lot
of things at Google.
I've been at Google
almost eight years.
But in the Google
Cloud Platform,
what I've done
recently is I have,
with a couple of
co-collaborators
a couple years ago, had this
crazy idea that maybe we
should open source
some of our ideas
in cluster management, the Borg
software that runs everything
from search to Gmail
and everything,
and actually all of
the VMs and everything
that the Google
Cloud Platform runs,
that we should build
out an open source
version of that software.
And we started doing that.
It came out a little
under two years ago
as a project called Kubernetes
and it's grown from there.
And so, we just keep trying
to push that forward and help
everybody compute like Google
does, whether they-- actually,
honestly, whether they're on the
Google Cloud Platform or not.
So, really believe that we want
it to go into people's data
centers, as well as being
available on the Google Cloud
and wherever they happen to
be running their compute.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we actually
had some cool demos
about it today.
We interviewed Kelsey
Hightower two weeks ago or so
about Kubernetes,
one of the two.
Can you tell us a
little bit about what's
your favorite feature from
Kubernetes, one of the two,
if you had to choose one.
BRENDAN BURNS: If I
have to choose one,
I mean it's like your children.
You're not supposed to choose
your favorite children.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: They're
not listening now.
BRENDAN BURNS: Oh,
they're not listening?
All right, I don't know.
The features have ears.
What is my favorite feature?
Well, I mean, I'm really happy
to see a couple of things
go GA.
So, I'm really happy to see the
work on things like autoscaling
and stuff like
that get to a place
where it's done-- I mean,
well, nothing's actually done,
but-- to the point where we
really say this is reliable.
This is production grade.
You can go out and do it.
I think it's important to
introduce new features.
I'm excited to see
things like the Daemon
Set and the ConfigMap.
I'll talk a little
bit more about those.
It's important to
introduce new features,
but it's also
important to make sure
that things move through that
beta production ready out there
and people can use
it, kind of cycle,
because it shows
that we're not just
throwing new ideas out there.
We're actually finishing
off the ideas that we have.
I'm really excited
to see that happen.
I'm actually really excited.
ConfigMap is one of those
things I'm really excited about.
Config is a big,
important problem
for people doing
distributed systems,
and so I'm excited
to see that happen.
And I'm also excited because
it's an example of something
that was largely built by
people outside of Google,
and so that was always
the promise of open source
was the community, and
community development,
and engaging with
people who are using it.
And so, it's really nice
to see that as well.
It's a great feature
for everybody,
but it's a great feature
that Google didn't build.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So, of course now I need to
ask, what exciting things
do you think you're going
to see in the future?
BRENDAN BURNS: So, what
I was just working on
on the plane on the way down,
which is most of the way in,
but didn't quite
make it into 1.2
is the idea of third party
extensions to the API.
And so, what this basically
allows you do with your cluster
is introduce your own API types.
MARK MANDEL: Ooh.
BRENDAN BURNS: Right.
So without recompiling it,
without doing anything,
you can walk up to the
cluster and you can say,
I have this new great
object called a foo
and I want to start
managing a foo.
I don't really want to
worry about storage.
I don't want to really worry
about optimistic concurrency
and if multiple people update
something at the same time.
I don't want to have to
do any of that logic.
But I have this new foo
object that I want to manage.
And so you create a foo
resource on the server.
And suddenly you have
this new resource type
that you can play around with
that works with all our command
line tooling, that works with
all our client libraries.
I'm pretty excited
about that, because I
think that's going
to unlock people
building Kubernetes plugins.
We're in a world
right now where if you
as a vendor, or you
as a third party,
or even inside of
Google, if you want
to deploy something
inside of Kubernetes,
you have to land it
in our code base.
You have to get it committed.
You have to go through
our code review process.
You have to do
all of this stuff.
And then we have to
maintain it, and so it's
awkward on both sides.
It's awkward for the
owner who really-- they
want to own that
thing independently.
And it's awkward
for us, because we
have to-- when we
change something--
we've got to fix your code, even
though we might not actually
understand your code that well.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
BRENDAN BURNS: And so, I'm
really excited because I think
it's going to enable a lot more
rapid development and a lot
more distribution
of ownership that's
going to make the project
even more scalable
than it already is.
So, that's probably
the thing that I'm
most excited about for 1.3.
Ubernetes is another thing
that I think is pretty awesome.
There's going to be some talk
and discussion about that
here as well, I think.
And that's basically
enabling you
to manage multiple clusters,
taking a global view
on your cluster footprint
instead of an individual data
center view.
So, I'm some pretty
excited about that as well.
MARK MANDEL: No, I've
definitely been speaking
to a lot of people who want to
have that cross region or cross
cloud or different data center
type management solutions,
and they're pretty
excited about Ubernetes.
BRENDAN BURNS: For sure.
Yeah, that's one of those
ones where I was like,
can you at least let us get
done with what we started?
And we were like, here
it's this awesome thing,
and then everyone's, like,
but what if I have two?
And we're like, we
still [INAUDIBLE].
Pretty soon once it's
done, you're ready,
they want to go
to the next thing.
So, it's great to see that
starting to happen as well.
Yeah, and again,
that's a great example.
Google's doing a
lot of work there.
Quinton Hoole is doing
a lot of work there,
but Huawei-- the Chinese
telecom company--
is also heavily involved
in that process.
So again, it's
really nice to see
that community coming together.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So, we know you're here
to speak at GCP Next,
so what are you going
to be talking about?
BRENDAN BURNS: We're mostly
going to be talking about 1.2.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 1.2 market?
BRENDAN BURNS: Yeah,
some people are Cube-Con,
but I think Cube Con is a
little bit more-- first of all,
it was in Europe,
and so I actually
didn't get to travel
because family and all that.
And I think it's more of
a Kubernetes audience, not
necessarily a full
general cloud audience.
And so, I think
here we're really
going to try and highlight
Kubernetes for people
who haven't seen it before,
Container Engine for people
who haven't seen it before.
Not too much on that,
because I think we've mostly
gone over that hurdle.
But then a lot about what
is the stuff that we've
introduced, how does
it make building
distributed systems easier.
Because at the end of the day,
that's what we're really about.
It's like, let's build
reliable distributed systems
in an easier way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
sounds like a great talk.
Were you here on time
to follow the keynote?
BRENDAN BURNS: I followed the
keynote on Twitter on the plane
on the way down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ah, nice.
BRENDAN BURNS: I didn't actually
get a chance to be here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What was
your favorite announcement?
What did you get the
most excited about?
BRENDAN BURNS: Well,
I mean, I'm pretty
excited to see that the dem-- to
plus plus the demo that I did.
So, I did this demo at
Cube-Con in December.
I did this one million QPS demo.
So, for Kelsey and other
folks to take that and really
take it to the next level, I
thought it was really awesome.
I mean, that's a little bit
self-centered, I guess, but--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's OK.
It was an awesome demo
to be honest, yes.
BRENDAN BURNS: I thought
that was pretty awesome,
so I'm hoping that
generates some buzz.
Not a demo that was on
the stage this morning,
but another announcement that
went out this morning that I
thought was pretty
awesome as well
was TensorFlow, which is the
open source machine learning
algorithm that we--
no, I shouldn't say we,
but the folks at
Google have released.
They just put out instructions
for running a distributed
version of that on
top of Kubernetes,
so doing image recognition--
MARK MANDEL: Nice, nice.
BRENDAN BURNS: --all
the way out in the open.
You don't need
any-- you can do it
on your own stack of computers.
So that went out on
the Kubernetes' blog
post this morning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
BRENDAN BURNS: I was pretty
excited to see that land as
well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
didn't know about that.
We will definitely put
it on our [INAUDIBLE].
BRENDAN BURNS: Yeah,
no, it's pretty awesome.
I'm definitely
excited to see it.
They do some image
recognition stuff
that's pretty cool, so
kudos to those guys.
MARK MANDEL: And
have you had a chance
to wander around and have a
play with any of the playground
things here at the event?
BRENDAN BURNS: No, I'm not.
I just came in the
door, so I'm going to--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
just got here on time.
BRENDAN BURNS: I walked
right by and you grabbed me.
So, no, I'm going to take
a chance to look at it.
I saw some old video
games over there.
I might have to go check out the
Tetris thing there from the--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
incredibly lots of fun.
BRENDAN BURNS: Oh,
I would imagine.
No, it's been a while
since I played Tetris.
I see Kelsey doing that
demo, but yeah, it's
been a while since I
played Tetris so I'm
excited to give that a whirl.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Well, thanks so much
for talking to us.
BRENDAN BURNS: No
problem at all.
And thanks for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And see you later.
MARK MANDEL: See you later.
BRENDAN BURNS: Thanks a lot.
MARK MANDEL: So, that was a
great conversation that we
had with Brendan at GCP Next.
I actually really
enjoy going back
to listen to the highlights
in some interviews
we have from GCP Next.
It was a really great event.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we
still have a bunch of them.
So, maybe next episode
we'll add some--
MARK MANDEL: Keep
flooding them in.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We'll sneak some
of those interviews in there.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
actually, before we
go with the main
content, there's
also if you thought that this
interview was interesting,
you should definitely
check our episode number
16 that we had with
Kelsey Hightower,
also on the topic
of Kubernetes 1.2
and all the things
that we release.
So, make sure you check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
That was also a really
interesting conversation.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, why don't we
go to our main
content of the week?
I just renamed that
section right now.
So, we're going to be
talking to Rae Wang.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Why don't we have
a chat with her?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Today,
we are joined by Rae Wang
to talk to us about IAM.
How are you doing today, Rae?
RAE WANG: I'm doing great.
Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, why don't you
tell us a little bit
about yourself first?
RAE WANG: OK, hi, I'm Rae.
I'm a product manager working
on Google Cloud Platform.
I look after the
IAM part of GCP.
I'm based in the
Google Seattle office,
and I have been at
Google for three years.
Before that, I worked in
other software companies
for over a decade.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
cool, and could you
tell us a little bit about
what is exactly IAM, you said?
RAE WANG: Yes, IAM,
it's three letters.
It stands for Identity
and Access Management.
Well, if you're
security guru, you
might say it means
authentication
and authorization.
What it basically is
is there's two parts.
The I part and the AM part.
The I part also is-- it
means authentication.
It's how you define the
identity of a user or a program
and then be able to
verify the identity-- you
are who you say
you are when you're
trying to access GCP resources.
And then you have the AM part,
which is access management
and that's your access
policies, authorization.
It's where you define who can
do what on which resources.
So, then when you put
the two parts together,
they safeguard your
Google Cloud resources
and they make sure that only
people that you want them
to access certain
part of GCP can
access the specific
resources that they
are allowed to access.
MARK MANDEL: So, you mentioned
resources a number of times.
What does resources mean?
Is that just parts
of the console
or does that mean actual things
that are running in the cloud?
What does that refer to?
RAE WANG: Well, resource
at the most basic level
is a thing you can use in Cloud.
For example, a virtual
machine is a resource.
A cloud storage
packet is a resource.
But then we also lifted a
little bit higher because just
managing the [INAUDIBLE]
a few thousand
VMs gets a little cumbersome.
So, then we have
high level resources.
Things like a project
in GCP is a resource,
and it's basically a
resource container.
Underneath a project you
have your actual resources
like VMs, and storage,
and BigQuery, and so on.
But we also make the
project itself a resource so
you can search policies
on a project level,
and then they can be
inherited by all the smaller
resources underneath a project.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so that
sounds a little bit like when
we said we had project editors,
project owners, and project
readers.
What is the big
difference between that,
what we used to have, and IAM?
RAE WANG: Yeah, so, project
owner, and editor, and viewers,
the roles you had in the
past, they were IAM version 0.
They were the most
basic set of permissions
that you could grant to
users to basically share
your project with them.
Now, the problem that
a lot of customers had
was that they're
not granular enough.
So, for example, if you want to
let your developers just look
at the logs in a project
so they can do debugging,
you have to grant
them a project viewer,
and by granting them
a pure project viewer
they can not only see the
logs but they can also
read all the content of the
data store and storage bucket.
And if you're running
a reapplication,
the data in these
storage systems
could be your sensitive
PII customer data,
so it's not really
great for developers
to have access to that.
Another example we've
heard is a customer
uses a continuous integration
system to deploy updates
to their GAE app.
And when they do that, they had
to give the CI system a project
editor role, but by
having that role,
the CI system could
also go in and again
modify other things in their
storage bucket, other things
in compute, in networking.
That's not really
their intention,
so these roles-- we're
very first step, step zero,
but they were not granular
enough for anybody
to really secure
their resources.
And that's why we've
had to push out
the real IAM system
with granular control
in the last few weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, so it
sounds like IAM is particularly
focused around security.
Are there other reasons you
might want to use it outside
of security, or is that
pretty much the big reason?
RAE WANG: Well, security
is a big part of it.
Certainly securing
your resources
is the main intention of IAM.
But then there's
also, for example,
if you are using automation
to access GCP, if you're
programmatically creating VMs
or manage your storage packets,
you need to let your
program access GCP
and then now you have
the problem of how
do I verify that this program
is the one I'm intending
to have it access GCP.
So, another part
of IAM what we do
is to give you a feature card
or service account, which
is a way for you to create
a rollout account so
that your programs
can call GCP API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So that basically
means that now I
could have some bots that
do something very specific
and I could say they can
only do exactly what they're
supposed to do.
So, if for any reason someone
hacked it or whatever,
they couldn't do
anything extra, right?
RAE WANG: Yeah, exactly.
And then that's actually
where using service accounts
is where we see a
lot of times people
want very, very
granular permissions.
Your people might do a
broader job function.
But the service
accounts sometimes
can do very specific things
just to manage storage
or just to manage
a Pub/Sub topic,
and that's where
we see permissions
can get very granular.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent, so if
I want to get started with IAM,
how do I control what resources
I can access if I'm a VM,
or how do I do that?
Is it a command line interface?
Can I do it through the website?
Is it programmatic?
What tools have I
got available to me?
RAE WANG: So, we have support
for accessing your IAM policies
through both UI, API, and CLI.
And you set the IAM
policy on a resource.
And we just talked
about resource.
It could be an individual
thing like a Pub/Sub topic,
or it can be a
project, or it can
be above a project
like an organization.
So, for every
resource level that
supports resource-specific
IAM policies,
there is a common meta
API [? get to set ?]
policy and test
permissions, as well as
a common UI widget to
view the permissions
and change any of
the permissions.
So, it will look very
similar, but it can
be done on different resources.
MARK MANDEL: So, the
other thought I just
had was around resources.
So, say I have a thousand VMs.
Am I able to group those
together in some way?
I don't want to obviously be
setting permissions on each one
individually.
I mean, maybe I could do
that programmatically,
but is there an easier way?
RAE WANG: Yeah, yeah,
that's a very good question.
So, we talked about how
we layer the resources.
You have your basic VMs and
above that is a project,
and that's often where you
group the resources that
belong to a single service.
For example, that's a
basic level of grouping
and a project is there
for you to set permissions
so they get inherited to VMs.
It's a mechanism
to group our VMs.
But it's also the
basic unit for you
to set down things like
billing, and quota,
and a lot of the other
control mechanisms.
And that bar project,
some of our customers--
Google itself
included-- as you get
into [? call ?] usage over time,
you end up with many projects,
because you moved many
services onto cloud.
Google itself, we've got more
than 100,000 projects, and then
of course managing
them individually
is also going to be cumbersome.
So, we have introduced this
higher level resource called
the organization
node, and that's
the root node for your company.
And then all the projects
that employees in your company
have created would belong
to your organization node.
So, you can now manage
resources on the org level,
on the project level,
and then in some cases
for certain resources, on the
individual resource level.
All of these levels,
policies inherited down
this resource hierarchy.
So, for example, if you
grant your networking team
in your company, the network
admin role on the organization
level, that means that they have
the network admin permission
on all of the projects
and all of the networks
in these projects
underneath the organization,
so you don't have to
permission them individually.
MARK MANDEL: Cool, so I
guess that means-- great,
so that means you can really
choose which level it is
you want to be able to pick at.
You can go all the
way at the top, which
is that org hierarchy to,
say, all way down to VMs,
and just levels in
between as well.
RAE WANG: Yeah, that's correct.
So, on the org
level it's typically
your company central network
admin or essential admins,
people who are
looking after having
oversight over the entire
company's resources.
And on project
level, it typically
is about your team, who are
the people who are taking
care of a service together.
And then, on the
individual resource level,
right now we have the
support for a few pops up
resources and then GCS
BigQuery, but we can
add those two things like VMs.
So, that's where if you
share the amount of queries
[INAUDIBLE] level often
when you, for example, need
to let a particular developer
debug a particular VM,
or a particular storage
bucket for a little bit,
or you're sharing
a storage bucket
through an application when
you get very, very specific
about a particular resource.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I have to ask
the question, I know
our users were clamoring
for IAM for quite a while
and it took us a while
to get out the door.
But we talked about this a
bit before this conversation,
and I think you had a really
good answer for that situation.
Would you like to share it?
RAE WANG: I think the question
is why did it take so long?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, pretty much.
RAE WANG: Well,
a system like IAM
is something that almost
pretty much every single one
of our APIs go through.
Every time you make an API call
to GCP, it does an IAM check.
So, when we were
replacing the old system
to get it to the new platform
so we can implement more
granular control, we
really want to make sure
that it doesn't hurt
reliability anyway.
We need to make sure that
from behavior point of view,
from reliability, and latency,
and every perspective,
the new system is at par or
better than the old system
before we replace it.
So, we had to be very
careful about it.
It's like replacing
your plane's core engine
while flying it while
making sure your plane
is still stable and
doesn't drop in height.
So, we've had to do
extensive testing
and putting a lot of
infrastructure to make sure
that that switch is very smooth.
What we ended up doing was we
had the old system running.
We had a new system up.
And then while all
the real traffic
was going through the
old system, we sending
parallel the same traffic
through the new system,
play the Doc launch,
and then through Logs,
when we saw that all the
behaviors are identical
and the reliability
and latency are better,
only then did we switch
over to the new system.
And even after we
switched, we're
still keeping the old system
up for a while as a backup.
We want to make sure that this
transition is really smooth,
it doesn't hurt any of
the user experience,
and it's only for the better.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, I have a question, and
maybe the answer is no and then
it's a future request.
So, I'm imagining a
world where you actually
have just one project and a
bunch of computation instances.
And what you want to say
is that someone has access
to those instances as
long as the instance has
a specific tag.
Is that something
that we provide?
RAE WANG: Not today.
Right now you can-- when you
grant somebody an instance
admin role on a project
they get access to all
the instances in that project.
You could do a
little subdividing.
One thing we have shipped
is per VM service accounts,
so you could, by granting people
access on a per service account
basis, you could
say this person is
allowed to [? speed up VM ?]
but only of a certain identity.
But we don't yet have
the-- you can have access
to everything in this project
only when it's labeled x.
And I have heard from
a number of customers
the desire to do that.
We're definitely considering
that on our road map.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So since you're already
talking about the road map,
what else can we expect
to see in the future?
RAE WANG: So, one of the
first things we often
get as soon as we
tell people look here
at the 20-something beautiful
and new granular roles
we have shipped, but what about
this other role I really want?
BigQuery comes up,
monitoring comes up.
A fair number of
them-- it depends
on the particular products
you're using-- you
want roles for the products you
care about so you can give out
very granular permissions.
So, we're definitely
working on shipping
the next batch of roles
based on different services.
And we're also working
on giving you the ability
to make custom roles,
because for-- we're
hoping that in the
80% case you can just
make use of the
out of box roles,
and that's the easiest path.
It saves you a lot of work.
But for some of our more
advanced customers-- especially
in the case of, for
example, service accounts--
they want to tailor to very
specific permission sets.
So, we're also working on
making it possible to create
your own custom roles.
And then beyond that, also
we talked about the ability
to let you specify a
permission based on labels.
So, we call these conditions.
This set of syntax
allows you to say, yes,
grant this person such and
such role and such result,
but also only if either
the person or resource meet
such set of conditions.
And these could be labels.
It could be time-based.
It could be IP-based.
So, there are a number
of additional policies
that we're looking at that could
be added to the IAM syntax.
And also, of course,
once we allow
you to use all these granular
roles within a very custom way,
the next problem you're
going to run into
is that they become hard to
manage and hard to debug,
so we definitely
also want to invest
in the debugging experience to
make the policy language not
only rich but also easy to use.
MARK MANDEL: So, that sounds
like some really interesting
features.
I just wanted to backtrack
for just one second,
because we've mentioned
it a few times.
We talked about
service accounts,
but I don't think we really
talked about what those are
and what the relationships
those have with IAM.
Can you explain what they are
and how that ties directly
into IAM?
RAE WANG: That's a
really good question.
So, typically when you think
about-- when people think
about identities they
think about users,
a person who can type
a username password
or press a hardware key.
But sometimes,
especially when you're
interacting with clouds for API,
there's a lot of automation,
a lot of applications people
build that talk to APIs
not necessarily from
a user as a person,
but rather as a program.
And a program can't go and
type in a username password.
They don't work the same
way as human beings,
so we need to give these
robots an identity as well.
And that's where service
accounts came to be.
We need to have a way to manage
identities for automations
either around App
Engine, Compute Engine,
or around somewhere
else and have
them authenticate and be able
to access APIs in a secure way
as well.
So, that's a service account.
Now, since we're talking
about service accounts
account-type username passwords,
they're authenticated by a key.
So one or more keys can be
created for each service
account on GCP.
And then you can
basically use the key
in your program to let your
program authenticate who
has the key to prove who they
are to access the resources.
Well, if your program happens
to run on App Engine, Compute
Engine, then your life
becomes a lot easier,
because we actually
manage the keys for you.
The keys are actually
sensitive data,
because once you have them,
you can prove who you are
and access resources.
If you're running on one of
the GCP compute platforms,
then we keep the keys for you.
We [INAUDIBLE] rotate
the keys for you
so you don't have to worry about
losing them or leaking them.
And if you're running a
program somewhere else,
you can download the keys to
be used in your own program,
but please take care of
them because they basically
open a door to your resources.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, I think we're running
out of time just a little bit,
but is there anything
about IAM that you
want to mention that maybe
we haven't covered yet
or haven't talked about yet?
RAE WANG: So, one thing
I want to bring up
is in my conversation with a
lot of customers, what we often
find is that people tend to
think of IAM when they have
a security incident, when things
get a little out of control.
But the best way to
actually plan for IAM
is to plan ahead before you
get to the point where you go,
holy crap, I've got to
tighten down security.
A lot of the planning is--
we'll talk about on the resource
level how you set up your
organization, how you lay out
your projects, and
what groups you set up.
And some of these
higher level concepts
are much easier to think about,
to decide, and to lay out
before you've already
got an application
running, last minute trying
to tighten up security.
So, do a lot of
thinking ahead of time
about how you want to
arrange your resources,
how you want to
set your policies,
and that will help your
apps to go a long way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That sounds like a very
good piece of advice.
Well, thank you very
much for your time, Rae.
I learned a lot.
RAE WANG: Thank you.
I really enjoyed talking
to you about IAM.
MARK MANDEL: Much
appreciated, thanks so much.
RAE WANG: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so much
to Rae for joining us today--
really appreciate
having that chat.
I have a much better
appreciation now of Identity
and Access Management.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
Yeah, very interesting.
I learned a lot,
and I'm actually
going to start using that next
time I have a bigger project.
MARK MANDEL:
Definitely, absolutely.
But why don't we talk about
the question of the week?
I think this one's a
little interesting one.
So, we've had cloud
storage for a while.
So, if you have a
static binary asset
you want to put in the
cloud and have edge caching
all over the world,
cloud storage
has always been great for that.
But the question
always comes up,
like, what if I'm
dynamically creating content,
maybe images, or sound
files, or movies,
and I want to also have that
edge caching around the world.
How can I do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, even
if those images are just
stored in some hard
disk and you just
have a web server serving them?
How do you--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So there's
actually a great thing
that we added recently, which is
what we call Google Cloud CDN.
And CDN stands for Content
Distribution Network.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And it's in beta.
And what this is is
basically just something
that you can add on top of any
HTTP or HTTPS load balancer
and it allows you to do
exactly that, cache requests.
The way it works is just by the
simple-- the traditional HTTP,
HTTPS caching mechanism.
So, you have those
headers and we're
going to cache the responses
to the requests that
have the method is get and
the answer is like 200.
And there's a bunch
of specific constrains
to decide if something
is cached or not,
so just go check it out on
the [? documentation. ?]
The interesting thing is that
it is very, very easy to set up.
So, once you have
your load balancer,
everything you need to do
is just click on a check box
and that it.
You're ready to go, and
now you have a cache.
As soon as you have cache,
the next question is cool,
how do I invalidate it?
That always happens.
And it's actually very simple.
If you've used Memcache
on App Engine where
you have that little console
where you can go and look
for a key and just remove
it, same thing pretty much
but instead of
going to Memcache,
you're going to go to the load
balancing page in networking
and find the
caching tab and just
remove it there-- very easy.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So, I could set up a VM that
could have some job that serves
out assets maybe dynamically.
Maybe it generates them,
something like that,
and then just put an HTTPS
load balancer on it, and boom,
I'm good to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so,
as a test of what I did
is I just had a bunch of
machines in an instance group
and I created a load
balancer on top of that.
All of them were running
Engine [? XO. ?] That's it
and it works very well.
Also, it could be
really easy to do
if you're running on
GKE on container engine,
because when you
create a service
and you said that the service
type is load balancer,
it will actually
create a load balancer.
So, you just go there and click
on Start Caching and that's it.
It's ready go.
MARK MANDEL: Nice trick.
I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So, before we go, I
totally want to mention
a couple interesting
new developments.
Most recently we--
we as in Google--
have announced that podcasts are
available on Google Play Music.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yay.
MARK MANDEL: So, you can now
get the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast on Google
Play Music as well.
If you go to our website,
check the Subscribe button
or the About section.
You'll see that we're
available there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep,
which is pretty exciting.
And on top of that, I think
that you can now find us there,
and also you can now
subscribe to our mailing list?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so we have
an email subscription option,
if that was something
you were looking for.
We had a few requests for it.
So, yep, now you can go there,
put in your email address,
and we'll send you
an email whenever
a new episode comes out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
since we're already there,
why don't we remind everybody,
all of our listeners,
how to get in touch with us?
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
So, via email its
hello@GCPPodcast.com.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going to
start with the one I always
forget, which is Slack.
We have a podcast channel
on the Google Cloud
community, Slack community.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
yes, absolutely.
And actually, I just updated
our About section, too,
so if you're looking for
a little more information
about how to get on that
Slack community, that's
all in the About
section on our website.
Twitter is GCP Podcast.
Google+ is +GCPPodcast.
Reddit is slash r GCP Podcast.
And that's it.
We're done.
That's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And that's it.
MARK MANDEL: It's OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, actually
the web page is GCPPodcast.com.
You did not mention that.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, there we are.
There you go.
So, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, so where are we
going to find you next week?
MARK MANDEL: Next week I
am taking a little trip
down to Kentucky.
I will be at Vector Conf
and then also hitting up
the Louisville GDG talking to
them about some communities
and talking at Vector Conf about
how cloud can change your game.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: And yourself?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going to
have a slightly longer trip.
I'm going to Budapest in
Hungary for Craft Conf.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very,
very excited about that, so
if you're around, come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Francesc, thank you
so much for joining me yet
again this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you
again for joining me, Mark,
and talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]